- I know a lot of people,
their first like, you know,
version of listening to Lady Marmalade
was the Pink and
Christina all that version
but mine actually,
actually you were my first,
'cause I had people that showed me
really great music when I was a kid
but my first version of hearing was you,
was your version of Lady Marmalade.
- Sarah Dash and Nona Hendryx.
- Labelle.
- Yeah but did you know?
I heard you didn't know
what the lyrics were about.
- I had no clue what that song meant.
(audience laughs)
I just knew that it was
a phenomenal like a hook.
- [Kelly] You get to wail.
- Voulez-vous coucher avec moi ce soir,
and then later I found out
the nuns thought we were
bad people, the nuns!
(audience laughs)
For singer a song about a hooker.
- Oh my gosh.
- I said, what hooker?
- What hooker (laughs).
- I said what hooker,
I just know I love that
melody and the song itself
and so I found out they were upset
and I said here's the deal,
you don't take a mattress from a hooker,
let her make her money.
- Let her make (laughs).
- They gotta make their money.
(audience laughs)
- I ain't stoppin' it, work girls work.
- It's not my dream but it's theirs.
- It's theirs right?